[Music]
[Applause]
meet Brian Keith Joseph the California
violinist who defied his own health
condition and shredded the America's Got
Talent sick
what did it feel like for you being up
on that big stage it was unreal to just
hear them speak my name and that's
something I think stuck with me this
whole time was just Simon seen Brian out
of his mouth right now so humbling
experience thank you was it like having
Tyra right there in the background like
for you cuz you know she's there at the
mama bears ira made my day okay I'll be
honest she gave me a little boost okay I
was backstage and right before I'm going
on for my audition I saw ty right hey
and she turns around waves back and says
high cheekbones I don't know about you
but I think I'm gonna go ahead and try
out for America's Next Top Model next
year but she definitely gave me a huge
boost of confidence they're stepping on
that stage and and and sharing your art
is a vulnerable thing as it is but you
also opened up about your health issues
three years ago I was diagnosed with a
serious nerve disease that takes away
the feeling from my hands and my feet
this basically left me bedridden
throughout my later high school in early
college years just bedridden not able to
play my violin much less honestly walk
to the bathroom and anything physical I
was so sad and the only thing that could
ever make me happy that always would
make me happy was my violin Ryan says he
hopes his story inspires other kids to
chase their dreams no matter what and if
he wins that million dollar prize he's
putting his money where his mouth is one
of the biggest plans I have with this
money is really to create opportunity
for people like me because I feel lucky
yeah okay I feel very very very lucky I
just feel like I broke out of something
that almost people would say would
definitively say you know you can't do
this turns out that's not true
totally and if that's not true for me
then it's not true for anyone else
you